foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Christina Ellis number one
best-selling author Ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number is a free call and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five bill is in Harrisburg
Virginia Harrisonburg Virginia to start
off this hour hey Bill how are you I'm
doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
hey so I'm 41 years old my wife and I we
entered baby step seven one year ago
when we paid our house off way to go
that was net worth is about 900k and
comes about 210 per year and uh we uh
thanks to your teachings we we have
moved forward in our financial lives um
and and we are just loving it uh we have
a new baby at home we have that brings
the grand total to two uh our
investments
um I'm maxing out my Roth 401k and my
HSA and I'm also investing in my 529 for
my for my two children so my question is
this I want to get into
um some bridge and vaccines that will
give me some income ahead of the typical
retirement age I think I want to get
into investing in rental properties so
my question is should I be maxing out
all Ross Ira accounts for my wife and I
before I do any type of bridge and
vaccine because I think there's a little
bit of room to do all of it
I did when I was at your stage and what
we're talking about is a fourteen
thousand dollar swing with a two hundred
thousand dollar income so it doesn't
matter
I mean if 14 000 keeps you from your
Bridge thing winning it probably wasn't
going to win
true yeah that's very true yeah so it's
not enough that it matters if it was a
hundred thousand that we're talking
about then yeah I might I might say
don't do it and let's work on the bridge
because you're smart to do the bridge
so what I did is just maxed out
everything just because I hate freaking
taxes
and I put as much money in anything I
can put in that the government keeps
your hands off of what you're doing you
got your Roth 401k you got your HSA you
got all that going and then once I had
all that back and you know you do your
back door roths and your case to do
individual roths and
um then that would get you another 14 in
there but then or 13 anyway but the um
uh and then I dump money into an S P 500
until there's enough in there to buy a
piece of Real Estate
yeah so I can do that and you know with
my employer I can do I can do within my
retirement plan I can do a Ross backdoor
Roth all the way up to like 50 Grand a
year so there's a lot of options but I
really want to get into that rental real
estate area so I think what I'm going to
do is how are you getting to 50. well so
with with the account so basically I
think I can do 20 22 22 000 a year once
I hit that Max
um I can I can it's through Fidelity my
company around 50 000 a year uh total so
what I can do after I hit that 22 I
cross Fidelity and say hey with the it's
an after-tax
um input into the 401K but then you call
them and tell them before anything's
invested they flipped it right into the
raw so it's it's essentially I would not
I would not do that much if real estate
and Bridge is your goal if you were only
doing traditional individual back doors
that's only 14k probably do that but I
would not Max I would not do that extra
25k I would use that towards your Bridge
I think I got the answer to my question
thank you so much for your teachings you
have incredibly changed my life you're a
40 year old millionaire making 200k with
a brand new baby I'm so proud of you
right when did you start this bill when
did you start this journey
I bought my first house in 2009 that's
about when I found Dave on the AM radio
in Virginia where I live and uh I just
became a student of the game I
discovered the podcast and uh been
living it ever since we paid off our
house it's worth about 475 last year and
uh it is true the grass feels different
under your feet once you pay that thing
off so it's it's incredible we're loving
it dude I'm proud of you well done
you're while we come down here and do
this every day that's very very cool
that's amazing and such a great
testimony for all the young people out
there who you know we're sitting here
saying get started now be consistent
over time this is what your life could
look like in your early 40s it's a
testimony and an inspiration for those
of you who do positive thinking those of
you who are whiners it's a mic drop in
your face okay so uh you can't do it
America's dad and my college professor
was Karl Marx and I think capitalism is
evil and yeah I mean yeah I can't help
you with that but uh Bill Kenny just
dropped a mic on you so there you go uh
it's good that's impressive and I think
that message needs to be out there
because we do hear so much negativity in
the Press here's the thing we are all I
mean this this culture there's so much
room
to be a complete screw-up and still
become wealthy I mean because we just
spend so much money you just did no
spend January I'm so proud of you thank
you no spin for a whole month no
spending from explain what you did
because it was inspiring well we only
spent on Essentials so no discretionary
spending and we made sure to stay under
a hundred dollars a week on groceries no
eating out no eating out no money for no
purchases on Amazon Prime no Prime
flicks that was hard for me that was an
Amazon fast it was an Amazon fast I did
not realize how mindless I was getting
with Amazon and it's ridiculous so what
what was the result of doing this we
saved kind of an embarrassing amount we
saved a few thousand dollars beyond what
we normally say Beyond it
okay beyond our normal 15 HSA normal
savings for the house we save twenty
four hundred dollars this month I that's
a brag two thousand four hundred and one
month in one month if people emailed you
that we're doing following you on
Instagram doing it and a lot of them did
more than that oh I had people saying
they saved over six thousand dollars and
you know what's really cool if you don't
eat out and you don't spend on crap that
you don't have to live right and you
limit your grocery budget to a
reasonable amount
uh you can save two to six thousand
dollars a month in a lot of households
which is what we tell people to do when
they're in baby step two anyway right
hair on fire scorched Earth drop an
atomic bomb on your lifestyle no eating
out no vacationing stop your whining get
your stupid butt out of debt and this is
what we tell people and you did it for
you not you're already out of debt
obviously but you you did it just to
prove what spending does to you and your
husband yeah well I was telling people
that you know I feel like our budget got
fluffy kind of like I did over Christmas
with all those cookies and it was time
to cut it back America is the definition
of fluffy
we're out of shape and we spin like
we're in Congress and then we whine
because we can't get ahead it's
ridiculous unless you did the no spend
with me then you are crushing it now and
we are winning oh this is a CrossFit
right here you just busted up into it I
like that way to go I'm so proud of you
thank you I'm proud of you leading a
whole bunch of people on Instagram to do
that too all it is is a nice little
wake-up call it's like a fast you
realize maybe I do eat too much all the
time
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
thank you
well you should have gotten your
W-2s by now your 1099s by now they're
supposed to be to you in the month of
January which means you're saying oh
Texas I love Texas said no one ever
um if you do you're just strange and you
should see a counselor but anyway so I
know taxes can be stressful we all hate
them and we've all heard that 16 of you
would rather get a root canal than file
taxes what well that's pretty bad I'm
pretty close though if I had to do my
own man I'm telling you hey if you want
to take the stress off of island off
your shoulders we can help you connect
with a Ramsey trusted tax professional
these guys and gals are CPAs or enrolled
agents they're not part-timers who swoop
in just during tax season they're
actually professionals and they live and
breathe taxes oh that's weird but
they're available for year-round support
of all kinds they have the heart of a
teacher and they'll get your taxes done
for you if you want to find out who we
recommend as a Ramsey trusted tax Pro in
your area go to ramseysolutions.com
taxpro and get connected today
ramseysolutions.com
taxpro and get connected today pretty
simple stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us so let's continue on
the no spend January thing that you did
it's pretty impressive you saved over
two thousand dollars almost three you
know 2400 you said right twenty four
hundred and it was not eating out not
clicking on Amazon and limiting your
grocery budget and not buying anything
that really you didn't need to do life
yeah nothing discretionary nothing
unnecessary a lot of people following
you on Instagram had even better results
there's a lot of fluff in our fluffiness
out there where fluffy fluffy fluffy
fluffy fluffy fluffy so uh what are some
of the responses you got yeah you had a
whole bunch of people following you gosh
so many wins I literally was going
through my Instagram before this and was
like you can't cry Christina you're
about to go on the show but I just
wanted to tear up because y'all killed
it it is so inspiring to see this so one
person said I stuck to no spend
challenge with you I just look at my
balance I'm ending the month with 2
942 extra oh my gosh just wow I've done
a no spend before but I obviously must
have cheated or something because my
income hasn't changed in the past year
and I do have to say I'm a little
embarrassed I've got so much money left
over clearly I was not doing a good job
at managing my money makes you want to
do your budget right I know that was
what I was thinking I was like this is
good motivation
um another person said on the debt
snowball we have paid off three thousand
dollars in credit card debt this past
month wow in one month in one month
somebody said we've saved sixty two
hundred dollars this January
right another person said they paid off
uh 550 another person said we're on baby
step six and we were able to pay an
extra three thousand dollars towards our
mortgage on no spend wow another person
said we saved five thousand dollars
during no spend January we're currently
in stork mode because we're adopting
twins in June and we saw just how much
we don't need right now wow loved it
somebody else said I reduced over twelve
hundred dollars in expenses grocery
subscriptions Amazon and mani pedis
oh that's that's not a yeah okay yeah
we've saved over nine hundred dollars
from not eating out and ate a bunch of
food at home that would have gone to
waste otherwise and the list just goes
on and on it's just incredible y'all
crushed it and I just want to say I am
so stinking proud of you like this is
just so inspiring to me and ah My
Heart's On Fire so good job everybody
who did this with me you have just
proved that you could win and so many
people said I was embarrassed I thought
I was doing a good job saving that's me
and my husband we save aggressively and
it's like we save quite a bit and we
still had twenty four hundred dollars
that was going to garbage like just
Amazon purchases that I'm not gonna
remember in five years like I'm not
gonna care about those purchases and
that's where our money was going it's
ridiculous I was eating I was eating
memories that could have been made I was
eating savings and so it's like all this
stuff with inflation groceries the
world's getting harder everything's
expensive we can still control our
finances we can still buckle down if you
feel like you don't have room in your
budget to get to the next baby step I
challenge you to do a no spend month you
will probably be surprised at the margin
that you do have but first you have to
commit to getting control of your money
and I'm just so ridiculously proud of
all the people who did it yeah it's very
cool me too so here's the message
out of this whole thing
not that you live
cheap
never buy anything and never go out to
eat your whole life
that is not what we're suggesting
the PO the beautiful thing about doing a
no spin month or getting on the baby
step two and just buckling down and
doing essentially the same thing and
throwing it all at debt which is what
we've been teaching for 30 years the
beautiful thing about that is it tells
you you can absolutely and but and then
you have the ability to choose at that
point to live like no one else so that
later you can live and give and spend
like no one else if you have eight
million dollars you can spend more than
if you're broke
okay and you can enjoy and do some
things than if you're broke and you can
uh we met a couple at the break here
they're driven all over the United
States they're out on a massive road
trip because they can okay why because
they got out of debt because they did no
spend and they realize that you know but
the the what we're trying to break here
is the mentality among a group of people
in America you might be among them I
don't know if you listening are among
them I'm sure someone out there is that
thinks that it's impossible to get ahead
in America today and our answer is uh-uh
you fluffy you fluffy you fluffy you got
fluff fluff fluff fluff fluff get rid of
the Fluffy and you can do this you got
you have margin if you quit whining and
playing the victim absolutely and it's
about getting intentional with your
spending like I said I was Fluffy and
it's like I don't want to guess can you
teach this for a living you work here
for God's sake don't get fluffy y'all
especially when you get in baby step six
it's easy to be like I'm saving 15 I'm
I'm doing a lot of stuff I'm paying off
a house and it's easy to get fluffy but
I also want to go on vacation this
summer I want to do really great things
with my kids that I'll remember I don't
want to go man we really need to buckle
back on vacation in memories that our
kids will cherish because I bought extra
stuff on Amazon that I'm not going to
remember yeah see what you never want to
do
again
ever with your money you need to be one
of two things you need to be intense
while you're trying to achieve a certain
goal and you're buckling down to where
your broke friends are making fun of you
like you joined a cult
how you doing that Ramsay stuff aren't
you yep
shut up you're broke and uh you're
you're in so intense that you're
freaking people out and that's like a no
spend a month right no eating out no
vacations right that's a that's for a
period of time it's not a life
if you're not intense what you have to
do is you have to be intentional
every dollar leaves under my command
I make enough money today and I have
enough money to do almost anything I
want to do
but I have to make I still have to leave
no dollars leave Dave and Sharon's house
without being under our Command so it's
not fluffy now it's it's doing some
things that we never dreamed when we
were little kids that we would be able
to do we just hoped but we've been you
know doing these principles for 30 years
it put us in a position to to give and
to live like no one else but it's still
it's intentional we're going to lay this
out we're not going to go oh I don't
know where that went
we're not going to ever have that moment
I have no idea where that money went I
we just we're just out of control it
just be we're just bleeding right well
even if you know where it went too
especially in this inflationary
environment if you're saving it's easy
to go you know what we're going to add a
little bit more to the grocery budget
this month and we're going to add a
little bit more to this one that's
unintentional but at the same time you
also need to go do I really need to
spend more in groceries or do I need a
meal plan better or do I you know what I
mean like do I need to really up my
Amazon budget or do I need to go oh it's
better if I eliminate stuff and just
decide I don't need as much stuff yeah
do you want to eat out every night or do
you want to go on a nice vacation this
summer I don't care which one you do but
you ought to do it on purpose
don't say I can't encourage you go on
vacation when you eat out every night
you can't afford you just chose to do
something else or we can't afford to eat
out no you chose to go on vacations did
you put the money in that pile and so
that's intentionality no whining no
victim you're in control tell your
freaking money what to do
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
good
thank you
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by Oracle including Ramsey
Solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory HR planning budgeting and more
All in One dashboard go to netsuite.com
Ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jump start your CFO career
[Music]
foreign
personality is our co-host today we
appreciate you guys being with us hey if
you didn't know this show started as a
talk radio show and it still is we're
the second largest Talk Radio Show in
America 680 radio stations carry the
show thank you for that and thank you
for those of you that listen on talk
radio you're how this whole thing
started of course when they came out
with a podcast the guy came in my office
and said we need a podcast and I said
what's that
and we were one of the first people to
start podcasting we put an hour of this
show on podcast and later on added the
other two hours a day to the podcast
um without commercials it is more like
38 minutes
um on a podcast and so a lot of you
listen on podcasts now and then of
course we've added YouTube and it's
exploded and millions of you are there
all told between those three there's
about 25 million of you in a week thank
you we appreciate you very very much
leave a uh a five-star review if you
would if you're in one of those uh
Technologies where you can leave a
review uh you don't need to bother with
a one star review mama said if you ain't
got nothing good to say don't say
nothing at all and that's a good plan
right there we don't need that help we
need the help though because it helps
the algorithms if you uh if you punch on
the internet that way and uh so leave a
nice review share it uh if you're
listening on talk radio sharing it means
tell your friends to listen to that talk
radio station if you uh click on it if
it's one of the spa modify or apple or
somebody you could send it around right
we appreciate that YouTube allows you to
share thank you for sharing something
else your mother taught you to do
there's a lot of mamas a lot of Mama
lessons here and uh so do that and just
help us spread the word the best way
this show if you listen you're listening
for free you're getting great
world-class advice for free the way you
can say thank you is help us spread the
word thank you for that we appreciate it
I just got a report in that uh it's very
very interesting for the first time in
history more people are listening
on a mobile device than on a radio
in the nation onto this type of product
okay some of the radio some of the
broadcast industry stuff and so the
lines crossed in 2022 for the first time
ever wow now our lines cross we actually
have a few more of you on podcasts than
we do on radio right now our lines
crossed about three years ago uh with
this product but we don't care where you
listen that's why we're everywhere we're
on Sirius XM you can listen on satellite
jump in there and uh next week we're
coming on TBN for an hour a day uh and
so you can jump in there TBN has done a
whole new set of programming
that is much more mainstream than the
old days and it's much more like regular
stuff than the old days and they
approached us and we were able to work a
deal with them non-exclusive obviously
because we're on everything so now you
can watch there there's 70 million
households uh get you know cable and uh
dish and all that that have TBN and so
not everybody not that I mean 70 million
people are turning it on but I'm giving
you the opportunity to turn it on it's
like five to six in the afternoon five
six in the evenings uh eastern time I
believe it is so you can find it on
there though it's pretty easy and I was
starting on February the 6th so thank
you guys for all of that the success
breeds success and you guys letting
people know is the number one thing
the number one thing so thank you thank
you thank you thank you Natasha is with
us in Virginia Beach hey Natasha how are
you
hi Dave thanks for having me on the show
we're honored how can we help
all right okay so my husband and I we
got married last year's anniversary
coming up on the 5th of February and um
from since then we've paid off all of
our debt we don't have no debt no car
payment get them we both own homes so we
paid off the mortgage of the home that I
was living in I had two children prior
to the marriage so I wanted to keep
their life kind of stable and we rented
out his property
um which is about two hours away so we
have some income coming in from that
um now we've also looked at a property
and we've started the process of
building a home
in North Carolina so the prices are
cheaper taxes are cheaper we wanted to
sell the house because there's no
mortgage on this house sell this house
take all of the money from this house
and put it on to the new house and we
will come out with a mortgage about a
hundred thousand dollars why don't you
sell the other one and be debt free
well the thing is this house has a lot
more I'll show both of them attached to
it huh show both of them
oh well that's that's an option but can
you pay cash for your North Carolina
house right
yeah why not yeah
well that's that's what we were trying
to do like what's the smart decision
because he was saying we could pay off
the other house and then move into it
but with the mortgage rate being almost
six percent it didn't make sense to try
and you know hold on to that the new
mortgage like paying that off
as quick as possible was the strategy
that I was thinking to do
so I thought you were keeping the kids
stable but now you're moving them to
North Carolina I'm confused well at the
time because it was in the middle of the
school year oh now it's like it's right
at the summer
um we could move within the summertime
and then everything would move smoothly
you know what I mean I didn't want to
transition but I have a grandson who was
about to start high school yeah okay how
much is the other house worth
the rental house inside the house is a
the one I'm sorry the rental house
the rental house is a hundred and twenty
one thousand dollars what's out on it
oh how much is how much is it worth
um sorry 220. oh it's worse 220 and is
we owe 120 oh she had 100 000 Equity
okay and how much mortgage are you
talking about taking out North Carolina
if you keep that rental
a hundred and fifty oddly enough
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry I'll tell you what old Dave and
Sharon would do we'd be debt free in
North Carolina with a grin on our face
all those other properties gonna be sold
okay and then use the fact that you have
no payments in the world of any kind to
start saving up some money and if you
pile up a little money you can buy you a
little rental there in North Carolina
where you can lay hands on it
right long-distance landlording is
dangerous and you didn't set out to be a
long-distance landlord it happened by
default
right it was never your plan it was
because he already had the house and
then you got married and he decided
living with you is a better idea and I
like his idea
okay well I'm talking about stability
for your kids being in baby step seven
having no payments in the world that is
a beautiful level of stability and like
days
yeah that's the scary part because we're
like we're in the midst of and it's like
we don't have a mortgage right now we're
about to walk into a mortgage well you
do have a mortgage you got a mortgage on
the rental
or a rental but we're not feeling it
right now but here's the thing here's
the thing you're gonna have no mortgage
anywhere
yeah if you do this
this is cool what do y'all make what's
your household income
about 70 000. I'm not working he's
working where are you moving in North
Carolina
um
where's that yeah
it's tight when you uh at the border of
Virginia and North Carolina it's like
new development it's like
and just going towards an egghead okay
okay I know where that is okay that's a
beautiful area
oh my God it's Stellar that is the
mountains that's that's something
incredible are y'all going there for
work
no no we can we can still get to work
like we're only 30 minutes away from the
house we're in now it's not really just
over the line yeah yeah I thought you
were going deep down you won't feel it
we won't feel it at all and we're and
it's two acres of land out there and
it's pretty that's a beautiful area am I
right
yes it is it really is a stellar yeah
sell everything and pay cash for your
new house
that's what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes and that's what you were
asking what would you do yeah same
That's so exciting that you have the
second house that you have the equity
all of that and talk about a way to
start off your marriage celebrate
anniversary all of that good stuff baby
step seven here you come that's amazing
ding ding ding ding ding ding I love it
so proud of y'all well done Natasha well
done got the house yeah this is good
this is very good this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Christine Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today we appreciate you joining
us hey a lot of you are brand new
listeners because a lot of you are
joining us on all those formats we were
talking about the other day and if
you're a new listener and you want to
figure out what this is it's kind of
like you know you're jumping into all
this uh Ramsay speak like baby steps and
uh debt snowballs and all these things
you don't know where you are and it's
kind of like trying to join somebody in
the middle of skipping rope or something
right so where do we do this well let me
help you if you're brand new
go to ramseysolutions.com click on the
get started button it costs absolutely
nothing
we'll help you figure out your next best
step
based on where you are today it's a
little quick survey on getting started
and then we will show you exactly what
to do
so it's completely free and if you're
going I don't know what they're talking
about half the time they speak in code
because we kind of do we've got such a
large tribe of people doing this stuff
that we all have our own uh thing I was
a funny thing Christian I was walking
through the airport the other day with
one of my buddies were going this thing
and a guy yells all the way across the
airport I mean across the the I'm coming
to see him March Dave and my buddies
like uh who is that and I'm like I don't
know and he said what do you I said he's
coming into his debt free scream and he
goes how do you know that and I said
because that's who yells through an
airport that says they're coming to see
me in March when I've never met them
it's code you're like that's our tribe I
mean that's it and so the other thing
you know stuff like that so if the
Domino's Pizza Guy
delivers your pizza
and you say how you're doing he says
better than I deserve that's code he's
working an extra job to get out of debt
double his tip
don't be cheap
so it's code you need to know the tribe
speak you need to know the code around
here and we'll help you with that right
yep
gazelle intense that's it yeah yeah it's
like some people will be going I'll have
my gun you know I mean stalker stalker
but no I know exactly what the guy's
talking about and it's like he and he
knew I would know right you know I mean
that's it so and also like the
enthusiasm level I feel like that's like
oh yeah signature for our tribe yelling
across the airport right everybody stops
and looks they're all got their heads
down on their phones right like
guacamole all these heads pop up but
it's like yeah we're having this
conversation my buddy's confused he's
like what is he talking about so that
but that's it you get because we do do a
little bit of that on here you talk
about FPU we have all these lingo what's
FPU Financial Peace University you know
it's like being in the military they've
got all these letters and you have to
know what all that stuff means and I was
never in the military so they start
talking that stuff and I'm like okay you
have to tell me what the acronym
all right Jan is with us Jensen
Winston-Salem North Carolina hi Jen
welcome to the Ramsey Show
your tribe says 2014. we are debt free
baby step seven
um he is retired already he retired
about a year ago
um I'm planning to retire from the
federal government in October at age 60.
um I'm wanting to know
um if I can if my tsp is Fluffy enough I
guess as you would say to uh take some
of some out of that to help pay for our
our retirement home
okay okay uh how much do you want to
take out and how much is in your
totalness stake
you'll have about 8 400 a month coming
in in his pension and social security
and that will be my federal government
pension without touching the tsp gotcha
and how much is in your totalness deck
his and yours combined
our total missed egg right now is about
nine hundred thousand we would sell our
existing home and I think we would
probably get around 200 for it
so so the tsp has 660 660 000. we
actually got 900 000 and you want to
spend how much of the nine hundred
thousand on the upgrade house
about about a hundred thousand of course
this is what you're doing
I counted up and were baby steps
millionaires but you know you're
definitely are millionaires and you're
going to drop 100 grand out of your
million dollars almost that you have in
mutual funds in your retirement and to
buy to add to your other house when it
sells to move up into your dream house
after you've worked your butt off your
whole life yes this is what you do
that makes me feel good because because
we're only thinking a 500 000 house so
if we can pull a hundred thousand out of
the Thrift Savings and then then we can
buy it all debt-free that's the only way
I'm gonna tell you to do it debt free
pay cash because you don't want to go
back in debt my God you got out
and we're hoping to not really touch the
principle on the Thrift Savings like I
said we're hoping for a long time at
least to be able to just live off the
tension oh I think you can 8 400 with no
debt good Lord of course you can yeah
leave a legacy for her kids yeah you're
well that's fine and or spend it I don't
care what you do or give it away but you
you're in good shape so and here's the
thing you guys are how old
uh he is 61 I am 60. I will be 60 in
October when I retire okay so when you
guys are 68 you're 800 000 if you don't
touch it and you leave it in good mutual
funds
will be 1.6
okay when you're 75
it'll be 3.2
sounds good so I think your hundreds
okay
y'all are gonna live a good life
I'm hoping to I'm hoping to travel move
a little closer to uh to a grand baby
that's coming there you go there you go
game on hey girl I'm so proud of you so
did y'all inherit any of this
um maybe
a hundred thousand okay all right total
between our two between our two parents
we did we did have my husband's home
place as a rental home for a while we we
inherited so are you millionaires
because of an inheritance or because of
your saving
we're millionaires because of the
savings yeah I think I think
mathematically that's an accurate
statement
yeah I'm proud of you
know we started your plan in 2014 and as
a result we've sent one son to school
totally debt-free uh he went to in-state
school we have a daughter who is still
in college but she has a fully funded uh
college fund she'll be going debt free
even if we spend the extra hundred
thousand on our retirement house okay
the plan works it does work and you
worked it so what'd you all do for a
living when you were working
my husband was actually our County Fire
Marshal
and I work for the Department of
Veterans Affairs so I kind of tune out a
little bit sometimes when you talk bad
about a space but yeah he's he worked
for local government for 40 years I have
worked for federal government will be 28
years and you're millionaires
we are just barely but we got there
way to go so proud of y'all that is so
cool and I love that they found you in
2014. so this is just eight years eight
years so for people in your 50s that are
thinking like oh it's too late they
already had a head start though they
didn't do the whole thing in eight years
right but people can still do this even
if it takes another 10 years I just feel
like we talk to people sometimes who are
a little bit older and they're like oh
man I wish I would have found this in my
20s or 30s and they feel like they
missed the boat you didn't you didn't
miss the boat I've been teaching this
stuff for 30 plus years now and I always
get the question am I too old to save
money and always say no not if you're
sucking wind
you can always save money uh now can you
is it as easy when you if you start when
you're 58 no it's harder because you
don't have the power of compound
interest over time working for you the
math doesn't work as easy but you can
still do it yeah and I've met lots of
people that became millionaires in 10
years and a lot of them did it starting
in their late 50s and uh so it can be
done no yeah it's wild that like either
end of the spectrum you could make an
excuse you could be young and say you
know gen Z is never going to be able to
become millionaires because of the
system being set up bad or you could be
old and saying it's too late and it's
like no either end of the spectrumic
problems with the economy I love when
they can say the word systemic I'm so
smart systemic they're so smart they
have a systemic problem with the economy
it's you you're the systemic problem
you're a virus I love the new words that
people are coming up with I saw one the
other day that I was like is that really
your word like what I don't even
remember it was something about gender
and race and mixing them together and I
was like I have never heard that word
before I yeah there's a lot of things
that people are coming up with there
that's for sure well I mean if you if
you need a new word just go to Tic Tac
they got one on there I'm sure they
don't all the best education coming all
the best education well I'm on Tic Tac
now so uh I heard I'm not but they're
our people here in the building have put
me on there apparently I'm a big deal
times are changing I'm a big deal on Tic
Tac if y'all didn't know I'm just saying
I'm a really busy I'm a big deal on Tic
Tac check it out this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsey show where Dan is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people do work
that they love build wealth and create
actual amazing relationships
thank you for joining us America
Christina Ellis number one best-selling
author in Ramsay personalities my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Natalie is in Modesto
California hi Natalie how are you
hi thank you for uh taking my call sure
what's up
hi um so
um I am currently on baby step two and
for work I am a federal employee
um because I'm a federal employee and
also the position that I'm in I am
deemed Accenture
in a in an event of a government
shutdown I would so have to work but
without a paycheck throughout that
during that period of a shutdown so with
that with the recent talks of of a
government shutdown this year which the
talk of government shutdown is always
it's always in the year every year but
this time it's actually making me a
little bit nervous so my question is
since I'm on baby step two should I
increase my my starter emergency fund in
case there is a government shutdown
this year
no
no no you don't ever increase your baby
step emergency fund what you might do is
you might push pause on the whole dad
gum thing and pile up cash
but just push pause on your whole baby
steps no baby steps at all are involved
it's we have an Emer there's a tornado
coming towards our house and we need an
emergency we need a big pile of money
okay so just don't even stop everything
and pile up cash everywhere if you think
this is going to happen
okay now all right how long you've been
a federal government employee
this is my
my sister the government shutdown since
I joined back into a little research for
yourself
how many times you've actually been shut
down
yeah hardly ever
yeah hardly ever yeah I think three
times in 30 years or something like that
yeah and the most recent one being in
January of 2019 it's just I'm feeling a
little nervous because
one maybe it's because I'm doing this
debt-free journey and into my co-workers
are out are you know making me nervous
as well so they're in talks of you know
raising their emergency fund or they're
saving up money in case they're doing
they're broke people
okay so what we need to decide what the
real threat is okay so if someone calls
me up and says our company is
considering layoffs
do I stop everything and build up an
emergency fund then the question is what
is the probability you are going to be
laid off
if it's less than if it's 50 50 yeah
stop build up cash if you think there's
a 10 chance you're going to be laid off
this is called worrying
just work your plan and shut up okay so
what do you think the probability is
after doing a little bit of research not
listening to your broke co-workers who
worry about everything but really
looking at it and saying okay in the
current political environment what
things are the same as they were during
the times that the three times it did
get shut down in 30 years or whatever
the number is I don't remember I'm
guessing but it's not far off of that
um and so you know and oh by the way
there's 14 times or 26 times that we
almost did and only three times they did
and so it's usually just a bunch of
hogwash and we keep working
yeah that's my yes yeah and if that if
you think you know okay there's a 10
chance this is gonna happen ah
go with it just just keep working your
plan hey Natalie how much debt do you
have
I currently uh 80 000 right now okay and
are you working a second job
no I work currently with my schedule I'm
currently working seven days a week
and um every six months might be
Saturday right now is at 57 a thousand
here that's my base salary but with
overtime I'm projected to make about 105
110 this year okay cool how much
overtime are you doing right now all day
long yeah that's a lot yeah yeah again
every six months our schedule changes so
um I'm like
I'm probably going to have this schedule
for the full year so I'm doing at least
75 hours of
working Saturday and you're not required
to do the overtime if you're if they
shut down
I am required no not overtime
on the factories that I work for so if
the factories are working I work
so they are deemed essential so I'm
essential so I'm most 100 I'll be
working overtime
because that the reason I'm asking that
is I'm thinking like if for some crazy
scenario the government shut down if you
had a side hustle if you had another
source of income that could be helpful
no margin to do that right but with 75
hours a week yeah yeah and before the
schedule
um I I had the time but again there's
the six uh our schedule changes from
time to time so I'm taking advantage of
the schedule I have right yeah I get
that and you're doing you're working
your butt off girl way to go I'm proud
of you yeah and that's tough and what
you're doing is a lot of hard work too
it's not like it's not wussy work this
is real work so
um yeah I
you have to decide what you think the
probability
with actual facts not whiners at work
but the actual probability of the
shutdown is and if you think it's 50 50
then I would stop everything in Polyp
cash I personally don't think this one
is 50 50.
that's a personal opinion but you can
look at it and say I you know because I
think what's going on is the jockeying
with a new Republican Congress against a
Democrat Senate and they're trying to
it's a power play the shutdowns usually
are power placed by the way but you you
know you've got a president on one side
a senate on that side and then you've
got the Republicans on the other side in
the Congress and so they're gonna
they're gonna push around and act like
they did something and then at the last
minute they're all going to sign up
that that's what they do 99 of the time
but that's just an opinion of from
somebody who has no respect for hardly
any of those people up there so Dave I
think we just need you to go to
Washington
we need you to run their budget there
would be a war we need you to teach them
how to build a war you don't want me up
there how are we running our country at
a deficit like we're we're not doing a
zero-based budget we're doing we need a
no spend month yes we do in the congress
come on let's go well then Sarah would
be back off overtime
or Natalie rather I'm sorry oh my
goodness sorry about that Natalie hey
you'll be okay kiddo I think you're okay
but you look at it and you make the
Judgment don't stop your plan based on
worries because worries are always there
but if the facts are scary then you
would stop your plan and pile of cash
that's the moral of story for all of you
facing these kinds of things this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day today is from Brian in New
Mexico you want to read it yeah my wife
and I are working on baby step two and
should be complete in less than two
years we're looking towards the future
and worried about how we will pay for
college for our eight-year-old daughter
I have an IRA worth 66 000 and I'm
thinking about moving about ten thousand
dollars of it into a 529 is this
possible and or a smart thing to do how
would it affect the tax side of things
if we do this
hmm
it's an interesting question I
personally and Dave you may have a
different opinion I would say if you're
in baby step two right now I would just
be worried about baby step two and
focused on that
um especially with an eight-year-old
daughter paying for college if you can
do that for your daughter that's going
to be a nice gift but given that she's
eight years old one you do have some
margin and time to save but also you
know there's a lot of different ways to
pay for college there's scholarships
there's tuition free schools there's so
many different options and right now I
want you all to be set up you know
getting out of debt and saving towards
retirement so I love that you're
thinking about the 529 but right now I'd
be more focused on baby step two exactly
yeah and no you cannot move money from
a 401k or an IRA to a 529 not without
paying the penalties for early
withdrawal so it's not an option number
one number two if it was an option I
would tell you not to do it for the same
reasons Christina just did so
um yeah let's don't do that and then
work your baby steps you're going to get
to baby step five at that point you're
going to start saving for college
into a 529 and during that time you're
going to get better and better at
managing money you're going to get more
and more margin because you're going to
have no debt except your home when
you're at baby step four five and six
working on paying off your house saving
for retirement saving for your kids
college
and you're going to you know have more
and more than you think you're going to
have because this doesn't work on a
straight line
uh you're looking at a snapshot of your
life which is today life is a film strip
it's not a snapshot it's going to you
things are going to change every frame
as you go along
generally if you're working a plan they
get better
financially generally
I mean sometimes people have setbacks
that they can't do anything about but
generally that's what's going to happen
so including your income going up yeah
you know getting out of debt hopefully
eventually being in baby step seven as
you get closer to college there's a
chance that even if you don't have a
huge pile of cash for to pay for her
education you may be able to cash flow
some of that yeah you know just don't be
adding you shouldn't be adding right now
to your 401k
you should be working your baby step too
you stop your 401k temporarily when
you're in baby step two and you pay on
debt smallest to largest and you're
working that snowball that way that's a
big deal
um and so it's smart to look ahead and
be thinking unless it causes you to get
into panic mode and start doing stupid
stuff and this is on the stupid stuff
list don't do this okay even if you
could don't do it now here's the other
thing well Christina the other part of
Christina's advice is the real answer to
your question the thing you can start
working on for her college is her
okay
um for instance we explain to our
children that they were going to
in-state schools
they were never really giving an option
on that
uh because it's what we're not going to
overpay for college and we didn't have
any pro athletes or um uh Geniuses in
the Ramsay house that got 4.0 okay so
they were like regular kids and they
were not going to be getting academic or
athletic scholarships we did not know
about Christina and the magic of
scholarships in those days uh and so we
said you're going to a state school so
College choice is something you can
start working on today
uh follow the correct football team you
know I mean so you know we don't want to
be confused uh and let's understand that
the parents run the house not the child
well my child told me they're gonna my
child didn't tell me stuff I told them
stuff
notice how that works well you're
controlling yup my money
you can count on me being controlling in
that case yep my kid you can count on me
being a controlling in this you can tell
your therapist about it when you're 30
but for right now you're gonna freaking
do what I say okay well and also it's
important to start having these
conversations about money in college and
then it costs money early on because I
talk to parents of seniors all the time
who are like hey I went home and I had a
conversation about college being
expensive with my senior and they don't
want to do anything but play video games
and I'm like well let's see have they
been active before like have they been
doing sports are they involved in
activities are they active you know
there's hardly any scholarships for
Mario right now hardly any there's not a
couch potato scholarship y'all not that
I'm aware of there's a lot of
scholarships but I'm not aware of that
one right and so it's like they don't
and then also school choice scholarships
plan on working so teaching your
eight-year-old how to work age
appropriately and how to make
value-based decisions what is something
worth what it costs and then how to look
for scholarships and do things that are
not normal that your friends don't do
and so we didn't go on a college tour
and visit 17 colleges we also didn't go
look at Mercedes-Benz when they turned
16. because they weren't getting one
so we there was no reason to be on that
lot because you're not going there
you know and so I mean it's you know so
we this is now if you want to do all
that stuff I'm not mad at you but this
this thing of you these people have a
sense that the college system is
happening to you when you instead can
happen to it and that's a bigger part of
the equation than moving 10 Grandy or
529 absolutely being proactive about it
having these money conversations earlier
instilling these work ethic and values
into your kids early on that makes a
huge difference talk to them about this
stuff tell them what the future is going
to look like talk to them about money
and scholarships and just doing that
they're going to be so much more
prepared that's why we have the student
loan crisis right now a lot of these
kids didn't know about money nobody
talked to them and the first person that
really had an in-depth conversation with
somebody offering them a student loan
it's a little bit mean and it's one of
the few main things Rachel Cruz says but
she says we don't really have a student
loan crisis we have a parenting crisis
step up Mom and Dad don't let your 17
year old your 18 year old do stupid butt
stuff that's going to take them two
decades to recover from right you know I
mean that's what amounts to and that's
you don't go 200 000 in debt to get a
degree in left-handed puppetry or German
polka history and then wine because the
society owes you a living
and I need to do I need good President
Biden to forgive my debt because I'm
dumber than a rock
well but it's it's not even just like
it's sad but it's also like these are 17
year olds they're they're inherently
like they're prefrontal cortex isn't
fully developed they're not supposed to
like they don't necessarily inherently
know all of this for those of you that
don't know that's their brain right it's
not fully developed it's not and so it's
like they're kind of supposed to be a
little dumb like that's just part of it
it's part of being 17. it's part of
being 7
we all made dumb decisions at 17 years
old but they shouldn't have so if you're
going to be attached if you're going to
pay 50 000 a year for college instead of
12 000 there needs to be a real reason
and you need to have the money or the
scholarships or the scholarship so you
went to freaking Vanderbilt you got a
degree which is like what 60 000 bucks a
year it's close to 70. now okay and so
you know we can't we're not saying you
all have to do what redneck Dave did
made his kid go to State College we
don't all have to do that so there's
nothing wrong with the Vanderbilt except
their football team so you can go over
there and go to school for sixty
thousand dollars a year but by the way
Christina did not pay a dime to go there
right and that was part of the
conversation with my mom and she's like
you're on your own paying for college
but you got to get scholarships you have
to figure out a way to pay for it
students
at freaking Belmont
right yeah was it your Master's is that
right or were you a PhD too I can't
remember Masters I'm not as cool
nobody's as cool as deloney but um yeah
so Masters at Belmont and that's like 50
Grand a year yeah 52 I think or
something yeah it's up there so you mean
you picked out two freaking expensive
schools but you got a half a million
dollars in scholarships yep pay cash for
both of them yep well scholarship
telling your business here girl but I
mean this is your business so that's why
I'm so passionate about it because I
felt those overwhelming feelings of like
how am I going to pay for this education
my mom's already told me I'm on my own
but I'm gonna figure it out and let me
just tell you
no one cares where you went to school
out here after you get out have you ever
asked your doctor uh before you give me
that shot where'd you go to school nope
or you hired that lawyer did you ask
them where they got their law degree
nope nope nope nope nope nope so you
need to go to school at a place that you
can pay for and that will give you the
education that will cause you to go win
as like a grown-up and stuff this is the
Ramsay shop
oh
foreign
[Music]
if you're not using pure talk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5G
coverage on the same 5G Network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over 800 a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with our 30-day risk-free guarantee you
have nothing to lose go to puretalk.com
and enter the promo code Ramsay to save
50 off your first month
foreign
[Music]
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book
confessions of a scholarship winner is
my co-host today we're talking about
student loans in that last uh question
of the day that came up and uh you know
one of the things that's happened in the
last week or so as President Biden
signed into law the new secure act if
you want to see a full
uh breakdown of the secure act we've got
a great article coming out on our
website at the end of the week so be
checking our blog at the end of the week
and it's going to be absolutely
everything you need to know about the
secure act but there's two things in the
secure act that were signed that uh a
lot of it most of it had to do with
retirement but two things they did that
were very cool
um that are helpful on this other issue
one is the law allows companies to make
401K matching contributions based on the
employer's student loan payments
even if the workers don't contribute
directly to their own 401k
so
apparently if I'm understanding this
correctly
um a lot of people a lot of companies
are helping with student loan debt one
way or another out there it's a hiring
process you know it's a hiring thing now
a signing bonus type thing so like you
got a match on your 401k that's a reason
to go to work for that company we'll
help you with your student loans the
reason to go to work for that company so
they're making this happen here and if
I'm understanding this correctly the
company can make contributions to your
401k equal to up to three thousand
dollars a year I believe it was equal to
your uh your payments on your student
loans
this is the same president that's
forgiving the student loans I'm so
confused but um they're not forgiven so
there we go
and um yeah this is the thing so
employers can match your student loan
payments with retirement contributions
this is correct uh uh here I mean I'm
trying to read the thing let's say you
get a new job making a hundred thousand
employer matches three percent on
contribution but you're still working on
getting Sally May out uh your employer
could offer up to three thousand dollars
of student loan I was right about that
yeah so you put three thousand dollars
down on your student loan they'll put
three thousand dollars in your
retirement account if your employer
offered that it is now legalized with
security that's pretty cool yeah there's
a reason to do your debt reduction you
know reason to get there and the other
one that's even cooler uh because a lot
of people gripe about well if I put
money in the 529 what if we don't use it
well number one that almost never comes
up because very few people put enough
money in the 529 for this to be a
problem okay but let's say you've got
thirty thousand dollars left over in
your 529 and you didn't use it number
one if you didn't use it because of
scholarships you can take out every year
the value of the scholarship so if you
get a ten thousand dollar scholarship
you can pull ten thousand dollars out of
your 529 no taxes no penalties you just
have to provide the documentation that's
already on the books but the secure Act
is allowing if after all of that you
still end up with because you went to a
cheaper school and your parents had
saved like maniacs okay and you end up
with money left in your 529 you can roll
it
after 15 years you can roll over any
unused money from a 529 to a Roth IRA
for the plans beneficiary
so uh Little Susie Q your daughter has a
529 and little Suzy Q
doesn't use it all 15 years later Suzuki
can have a Roth IRA and roll the money
into that with no penalties this is so
exciting to me that's a really good
thing yeah especially as a parent I mean
that's a discussion we've had in our
house and just a conversation and a
thought process and it's like wow that
is a huge change for parents well it
takes away the whining that says I'm
afraid I'm going to have too much him I
thought I'd do anything which never
freaking happens but it could happen
hypothetically and if it did number one
if it was because because of
scholarships you should have pulled it
out right then and not paying taxes
doing what we just told you that's
already on the books but now this act
the secure act signed by Biden thank you
President Biden good good piece of
legislation here I think everything in
this piece of legislation but one thing
I like we'll cover that another day but
these two student loan things one is the
employer can now match what you pay down
up to three thousand dollars into your
401k nice benefit and two this one's
even more important if you had 529 money
left over after 15 years you can roll
any unused money from a 529 plan into a
Roth IRA
the student to the student okay not to
Mom and Dad's Roth IRA but to the
students Ira which is this is just very
cool yeah just it's another way to set
your kids up for success and again like
you said to take those excuses off the
table
there's not a reason not to say for
college if you're in baby step five you
know and you think your kids are going
to go to college like that's a great
thing to do and you don't have that fear
anymore there's not that reason to
hesitate very good Sarah is with us
Sarah's in Asheville North Carolina hi
Sarah welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks
what's up
um I have a question about investing or
saving we have just completed funding
our six-month emergency fund way to go
we would like to thank you we're we're
very excited we we're doing the baby
steps so we're looking to increase our
investing
um but the question is we also have some
savings goals we like to pay cash for
our next car and Like Home Maintenance
things like we've been told we'll need
to replace the heat pump in our house
which would be several thousand so the
question is do we just dump into savings
right now or
up some investing what's your household
income
um we are a single income I now stay
home
um with my children and we're about
right at 90.
okay and you're gonna be putting fifth
baby step four is 15 of your income
going into retirement and then with
what's left over in your budget you save
up for a car and a heat pump
you don't have any payments anymore
remember
yeah and we have no payments right
that's the question if we dump that much
into retirement it's going to be hard to
have much to save no for a car no how
much debt have you paid off
uh
well we have no we have no car payments
how much debt did you pay off
um probably
15 000. how long did that take you
over how long probably probably two
years good lord well yeah you're gonna
have trouble because you've never cut
your budget back
how quickly do you need this car
um what the car we have now is 11 years
old and it I mean it's functioning we
hope to keep it as long as we can we do
not want to go into debt for a car of
course
so it's not an urgency right now what's
your house
uh we our house is paid for currently
we're a family of six
okay sure there's all kinds of problems
in this math and I don't know where it
is all right and I don't want to jump to
too many conclusions
uh my suspicion from my experiences that
you're not doing a good job with your
budget
you have no house payment you have no
car payments you make ninety thousand
dollars a year you have six kids lots of
people in your situation would have lots
of money left over after having put 1
200 1 400 into their 401K plan
you don't have a payment in the world
and there should be all kinds of room in
this budget to save not not buy a car a
month but you ought to be able to save
it and buy one by September you gotta go
save and do your retirement I think you
guys are
um
focused on uh you get caught up in the
busyness of a large family and sometimes
there's some disorganization in the
finances around that and we go oh well
we're a large family we can't afford it
sometimes that happens could that be you
[Applause]
know you know his like I said we're
single income do you do a written budget
every month every dollar has a name and
you and your husband are in agreement on
it before the month begins no you don't
yes you do
every single dollar has an assignment
okay then you need to figure out where
all your money is going do a no spend
month because yeah I mean it's you you
got 90 000 coming in minus taxes
and you should have money left over
to do retirement and to save for these
other things there should be room in
this budget I've been doing budgets for
30 years there's something wrong with
your equation here something's missing
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well sometimes the lessons in life that
you get when you screw up they hurt you
learn from them you've got the wisdom
and you don't have to do it again
and then you get to do something new
that's stupid but that old stupid thing
you don't have to do it twice right
that's how we learn that's how I learn I
try to not do the same stupid thing
twice and after you get older you've
done a whole bunch of stupid things that
you never do again so you get to be what
they call Wise
this is why we wrote The Total Money
Makeover so you don't have to make the
same money mistakes I made you can learn
from my stupidity uh before I learn to
do things the right way you get
practical proven plans that literally
tens of millions of people have applied
to get out of debt and build wealth and
learn the seven baby steps in my most
recent book baby steps millionaires
you'll also find out through the stories
of real people that you can be radically
transformed and become a millionaire it
can really happen anyone can do this in
America even today it's not snake oil
it's not magic it's actually very hard
but it's easier than being broke and
stressed
so try it anyone can do it never too
late you can order The Total Money
Makeover book you can order the baby
steps millionaires book you can order
any of our Ramsay personality books of
course at ramseysolutions.com
store check it out James is in Fort
Wayne Indiana hi James how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world
so I just have a question I recently
started listening to your podcast my
wife and I we recently moved into our
new construction home
um and we're just kind of trying to
figure out how to budget properly we're
both in our early 20s and I always hear
about the Money Makeover book and also
financial advisors and I'm just curious
on on what's the best route for someone
just starting to learn how to budget
properly to go
well welcome on board we're we're happy
to have you here our ratings went way up
we didn't know it was you
[Laughter]
so are you familiar with the baby steps
at this point
uh somewhat not all the way but I have
my my stepmother she preaches you all
the time and like I said I just started
listening to you guys and I just I'd
really like to hop on the train and get
this whole situation fixed well I love
this this is what we were talking about
earlier with all the acronyms and the
new lingo for the people that are just
starting out in the tribe so this is
just perfect
um so do you all have any other debt
outside of your house
um other than credit card payments no we
paid off our cars our house is being
constructed
um and we had a medical bill uh that we
paid off as well so we just had credit
card payment and house what is it how
much do you mean you have debt on a
credit card
yes okay how much
Seventeen seventeen thousand okay and
what's your household income
uh yearly it's right around this year we
were at 95. good for you you got a great
start sir great start thank you Dan I
love that you're already tackling you
know the car the different medical bills
like that's that's awesome the 17 that's
next so that would put you on baby step
two we have seven baby steps you're on
two and that's the next next thing we
want you to tackle and you asked about a
financial advisor you know we've got
these things here called smart Buster
pros and for a lot of people once
they're investing we recommend both but
right now
um you're in baby step two and well have
you taken Financial Peace University yet
I have not well we'll gift that to you
and that'll explain the whole system
you'll learn all the lingo and all the
acronyms and all the things that we're
talking about uh to just kind of get you
really focused and started yeah this is
the class that you should have been
taught that we all should have been
taught
um yeah I wish yeah I hear you me too
and so yeah but it's going to walk you
through exactly what to do and so right
now what you're going to discover is the
largest barrier to people becoming
wealthy is debt payments because your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income
so what we're going to do is quickly
wipe out that 17 000 so with no payment
in the world but a house payment you got
some wiggle room in your budget then you
can save for an emergency fund then you
can start your retirement investing
which is where you'll build serious
wealth and you can start saving for your
kiddos college so they don't end up in
student loan debt later and then the LA
the next to the last step six is we're
gonna pay off the house early that's
probably going to take seven eight years
to do that whole thing uh but dude if
you're 30 and you have a paid for house
retirement's well underway and you don't
have a payment in the world uh by then
you're making a lot more than 90
you're going to be so wealthy so fast
it's going to be crazy in the scope of
things see what we're doing
I do yeah okay it's just a system a
process of what to do first what to do
second and all of that and uh like
Christine said we'll sign you up we're
going to give it to you as our gift to
say thank you for being a new listener
we're glad you're here and uh and it'll
walk you through this but you you're
going to have there's a
there's not a path
to greatness that does not involve
strain
there's not a path to success that
doesn't involve perseverance
there's not a path to being different
above average
that does average things
so be ready for some prescriptive things
that we're going to tell you to do that
are going to feel
like your friends are going to think
you're crazy but keep in mind your
friends are broke people
and so that's what you you know if you
do if you get that then you go okay I'm
gonna lean in you know there's no pill
you can take
down at the vitamin store that's going
to make you look like a Greek god it
requires
unbelievable physical discipline well
it's kind of like pick your heart being
broke is hard being hopeless is hard
having no plan for your money and living
paycheck to paycheck that is hard and
while it takes discipline and it might
be a challenge to get on a plan and
build wealth that actually has an
amazing end result and it brings peace
in your finances the actual work is
worth it in the long run so then tell
your stepmother thanks for preaching we
appreciate it
hang on we'll give that to you brother
and you call us if you got any questions
anytime we're here to help you we'll
encourage you to uh Jessica's in
Louisville hi Jessica how you doing
hi thanks so much for taking my call
um I have a burning 5 29 question and
I'm hoping you guys can help me with
um so my husband and I have three
teenagers and a senior in high school a
junior in high school and a freshman so
all will be you know college ready soon
so we've been saving since they were
born
um as of right now we have 123 000 in
their accounts each when and total I'm
sorry and they're set up as three
separate accounts but I just kind of
look at it as quickly amount
um so we put 600 a month in there right
now
um I looked back last January January we
were at 128. since then we put you know
7 200 with that and now we're back at
123. so my question is
um should we stop contributing to the
529 and just leave it for them okay
because we're planning on cash following
the oldest because he's getting pretty
good scholarships we're requiring all of
them to do in-state tuition yeah so that
means you've got at least three or four
years before you're gonna need this
money
yes so
so keep keep going what do you think the
stock market is going to do in three or
four years if it goes three or four
years and doesn't go up it'll be the
first time in history
oh really
three-year bear markets don't exist in
history go look for them
okay good so um so you think we're baby
step seven so you think just
um should I pull some out for my for my
one that'll be starting in the fall
um cash flow the one that's starting in
the fall well I can because
you think okay leave this alone let it
grow okay I'll do it thank you so much I
just love that she's the word burning
and 529 in the same sentence I was going
to ask what a burning 521 was I haven't
seen one of those I'm like as somebody
who studies College it's like a burning
bush
that much excitement around a 529 just
gets me excited that's right I have a
burning 529 question oh no burning
question about if I was trying to okay
now I got it okay but yeah that's uh and
and so yeah that's an interesting thing
it's like it's kind of like when you're
coming up to okay you're getting you're
64 years old the stock market's down oh
I got a million dollars in there do I
take it all out because the stock
market's down no you're not going to use
it all right now let it ride ride the
road roller coaster
no one gets hurt on the roller coaster
except those that jump off in the middle
of the ride this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Christina Ellis
number one best-selling author and
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Lara is
in Maui Hawaii hi Laura welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi guys I'm so grateful for you guys I
wish I discovered you sooner well we're
glad you're here how can we help
um I just I don't know where to start
I'm I'm a stay-at-home mom my husband
and I have I have three uh little kids
one on the way uh one of them with
special needs and I made a lot of stupid
choices in my 20s and now we're about
200 000 in debt with most of it coming
from my student loans wow we have super
high living expenses there are like 60
of our income
um and I just feel like we can't ever
get ahead because we're always just
trying to make ends meet and I I know
that we live in expensive place housing
wise but I don't really want to move
because my daughter can get Services
here and you know I want my husband to
bring in more income either by going
back to school or getting a new degree
or taking on another high paying job but
I also feel like I needed help at home
because our kids are still young and I
just feel so stuck and I want him to
pick up his income but I also just I
don't I just don't know if that's the
answer or where to start no I'm sorry
kid you got a lot on you
a house full of little kids is enough
one of them special needs adds a double
dose doesn't it
yeah a lot going on how old are you
um 31 now okay
and the kids are what ages
three two nine months that alone just
spells cray-cray
you don't even need debt to be
overwhelmed you've got it right there
I don't blame you a bit I don't blame
you this is just a hard time for y'all
okay that's a lot of work there's a lot
of emotion a lot of drama in the air and
then pile 200k a dead on top of it right
okay yeah so there's not a magic switch
we can throw that makes us go away
okay in terms of the debt
um as you have already figured out and
alluded to there's going to be some
trade-offs
something's going to give
if you want this debt to go away and
you're gonna you're gonna pay a price of
some kind for this debt to go away I
don't know what that price is but you've
already figured out that that's your
only way right it's not because it's not
going to magically disappear
so
um and it's not bankruptible so it is an
income
versus outgo
formula you've already alluded to that
you know that
so it's income up
out go down
student loan goes away
now what's going to give
hey you guys get to make these choices
you're grown-ups but you can't sit there
and expect
uh Puff the Magic Dragon to show up he's
not coming
so hubby's not going to be around to
help you and you're going to be a little
bit even crazier in an already
overwhelmed situation with three littles
and one of them was special
and um it's gonna be hard and because
he's working all the time because we got
to clean the student loan debt up so we
can have a future
or
we move and we find some other way to
get services for the little
or
both
but you see what I'm saying something's
going to give something's going to leave
a mark something's going to be ouchy
right now the algae is the student loan
but if you want it to move away there's
going to be you're going to trade it for
another ouchie
does that make sense
yeah so embrace the suck
yeah you're right it's gonna suck you
just got to figure out which one and
what I like about this is you get to
choose your suck
I mean if we could if we had a time
machine we'd send you back and not do
this okay but you know hey you know if
none of us ever made mistakes I'd never
have a radio show so there you go right
so I mean this is how this works so
you're okay you're just a human being
and screwed up welcome to the race you
know we all do this right I got a PhD in
Dumb kiddo I've done stupid stuff makes
your stuff look smart
so I mean I get it but it's I but you
can't it's not gonna we can't just go I
wish no so so something's gonna suck
what is it and you and your husband sit
down and put the kiddos to bed get them
all asleep at one time which is a minor
miracle in itself and we're gonna have
it not We're not gonna watch Tiger King
on Netflix we're gonna talk about this
crap and we're gonna go okay what is it
in our life that for the next three
years is gonna suck and be really hard
so that this sucky student loan goes
away
mm-hmm
yeah
because you named everything you needed
to do you just didn't want to do it and
I'm I'm coaching you up here
yeah this let the spear Line in the Sand
moment I mean it's hard as a mom of
little babies too it is it is a hard
season but this is just gonna be a
season this isn't Gonna Last Forever
both with the kids being tiny and it
being hard and also with paying off this
debt yeah it's not 10 years from now it
will not be the same
yeah it won't be
I mean kids are easier to raise when
they're older
if you let them live that long they get
better
I wish I thought about a family in my
20s or younger so that I wouldn't have
made all the stupid decisions I made
well me too
I wish I wished I hadn't borrowed three
million dollars when I was 26 and gone
broke when I was 28 when Sharon had a
brand new baby at home and would have
left but we didn't have a car she was so
pissed at me she couldn't see I wished I
hadn't done all that but I did do it and
then I had to embrace the suck to get
rid of it
but do you recommend removed
do you think that would help us I'm not
sure
I recommend that the two of you look at
it and say what is it that's going to
suck and we're going to choose
okay we're going to choose your you're
going to go back to school and we're
take this job you're going to work 60
hours a week and I'm gonna be like a
single mom over here pulling my freaking
hair out we're going to move States
we're going to do all three of these
things but you know or we're going to
choose to sit in a student loan and look
at it and it sucks because we're going
to just keep doing what we're doing
right now but at least choose don't feel
like it's happening to you you choose
and when you do that you're going to
make a good choice
and you're going to make one you're
willing to embrace
Laura are you ready for that
um I'm scared but I feel like
there's a lot so yeah I'm ready I think
you're ready when you get when people
get sick and tired of being sick and
tired that's when they're ready to do
anything
and it's in your voice I can hear it you
you're you're over it you're done you're
like Something's Gotta Give
and all the fear and shame let that go
let that drive you forward like don't
live in that fear and that all Coulda
Woulda Shoulda like that's done it's
time to move forward
because we've all done it kiddo the rear
view mirror is smaller than the
windshield for a reason it's called
Grace
[Music]
thank you
if you're considering a career in
technology I recommend Bethel Tech and
I'm not alone here's what Brendan said
before Bethel Tech I was driving Uber
within four months of graduating I got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that I got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what I
learned at Bethel Tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net and
get one thousand to twenty five hundred
dollars off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net Ken Coleman
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm your
host Dave Ramsey one of my friends for
several decades now and uh
fellow authors fellow speaker speakers
here in our community Michael Hyatt
dropped by his daughter Megan the
President Chief Executive Officer of
full Focus their company is with him and
they've got a brand new book out so I
said hey Michael
get Megan come over we're going to talk
about this thing because it's awesome
because it fits right in with the stuff
we talk about every day around here
we're all about intentionality get up
off your butt leave the cave kill
something drag it home right mind your
mindset the science that shows success
starts with your thinking when I saw
that I thought of that old
uh gosh uh um my mind I thought of it
and then it left my mind apparently but
uh Earl Nightingale yes you know the the
old uh his first thing he did and it's
all about intentionality it's all about
you become what you think about this
yeah the secret of success you become
what is the name of that talk oh my gosh
I know what you're talking about talk
about it all the time but anyway it's
like what The Strangest Secret Strangest
Secret thank you James got me from the
booth yeah The Strangest Secret and uh
you become what you think about that the
science that shows success starts with
your thinking and that's that's the path
you all went down with this it is
because one of the things we realized in
art specifically in our coaching work is
that if you want to change somebody's
results
for most of us that are entrepreneurs
and business owners we kind of have an
action bias we think if we just redouble
our effort work faster work harder work
smarter
but that gets you so far but it's really
your thinking that drives the actions
and particularly the stories we tell
ourselves
and so I had uh I think you'll
appreciate this story but uh I had a
business that I owned back in the late
80s early 90s and that business failed
now all the assets were pledged so we
couldn't even legitimately go bankrupt
there was no assets to divide up and
give to the creditors but a few years
later a friend of mine said to me he
said you know you're not very good with
money are you
and I accepted that story
as my own never never occurred to me to
question the truth of that and then I
set out for the next several years to
prove that
because my actions flowed out of that
thought and it was when you buy a
negative narrative yeah exactly or a
positive narrative exactly and you're
you act on it because people act on what
they believe that's exactly right and
you don't do actions otherwise sometimes
you think you do but you just don't yeah
and James Clear is atomic habits he
talks a lot about resetting your
identity which in a sense is resetting
your your your belief of I am not a an
overweight person I'm a person who has
too much weight right
I'm a guy I'm a skinny guy who needs to
lose some weight you know I'm a I'm a
broke guy who's learning how to handle
money not I'm a guy who doesn't know how
to handle money well that was the story
I came to and frankly you had a big part
in that story I don't know if you
remember this was decades ago that you
met with Gail and me you were kind
enough and you began to reset that
narrative for me that hey I can learn
about money and I can get better with it
and the baby steps are all part of that
the book is mind your mindset the
science that shows success starts with
your thinking Michael Hyatt Megan Hyatt
Miller from right here in our own
community and longtime friends of Ramsey
family Ramsay show Ramsay everything you
need to get this book you need to pick
it up today it came out today it did
today's launch day yeah so buy it today
please it helps them with their
marketing on Amazon we want to run the
numbers up buy it today anywhere great
books are sold and you can check out
their website which is fullfocus dot Co
fullfocus.com which is their company
Megan talk about the work you guys are
doing a full Focus around this subject
particularly well you know we're
help unlock a part of success that
oh you know that we have some
have sauna get debt free we want to have
Financial Peace but there's something in
the story that we unconsciously are
telling ourselves that's keeping us from
taking the actions that we need to take
and so a lot of our work our coaching
work is not Financial in nature but it's
helping people to remove those blocks in
their mindset so so they can get those
actions in line and get the results you
know Dr John deloney talks about if
anyone talked to one of my friends the
way I talk to myself I'd punch them out
so how do you break out this thing
because we all got these tapes running
in our head I don't care who you are I
don't care how smart you are how studied
you are how many phds you have in
Psychology you still got a tape in your
head how do you break out this fact from
fiction stories so that you can uh you
know as you said I think a beautiful
phrase unlock yeah potential that's not
been unlocked well the first thing to
know is that your brain just wants to
stay safe it is wired to keep you safe
to avoid danger and so the fact that you
have negative thoughts there's nothing
wrong with you that's just kind of how
your brain works but you can be
intentional about actually training your
brain by going through some of these
steps that we talk about in the book
identifying your story interrogating it
and then ultimately imagine something
better that's going to give you the
results that you want I think Dave for a
lot of people the idea that the facts
and the meaning that we assign to the
facts are two different things that's a
new idea and that meaning that we assign
can sometimes service but as Megan said
sometimes it's just a brain trying to
get us to play a small game play a safe
game and not do the not have the courage
we need to to create the change we need
to have a better life yeah I think our
brains are drama queens yes they
overstate it and go get out of the road
no I think we're okay that car is like
two miles down there it's okay calm your
butt down you know and that that's the
thing that this narrative that gets to
running and it's like you're gonna fail
yeah right I haven't even done anything
yet how could I fail it's not possible
yet but I it's like these loud alarm
Bells go off and and so just recognizing
separating fact and that's a mental
exercise that's an act of your will and
it's a skill you don't have to know how
to do it innately it's something that
you can learn how to do that will become
automatic over time which I think is
helpful yeah we talk about this concept
of this narrator that lives inside of
our heads so if you're watching an NFL
game there's what's happening on the
field those are the facts of the game
but then there's the color commentary
these guys that can't stop blabbing that
are telling you every play what it means
where the games going and all of us have
that guy living in our head
but sometimes that that narrator needs
to be defanged or given a different
script one that's more empowering and we
can do that that's what we talk about in
mind your mindset exactly I mean if it
was a Twitter follower you would just
delete them right Bannon block them
because you wouldn't let somebody talk
to you that way you know at least if
you're smart you would you don't let
trolls happen in your real life why
would you let them happen in your brain
yep you know and it's it's reset the
thing mind your mindset it comes out
today the science that shows success
starts with your thinking Michael Hyatt
Megan Hyatt Miller you can get it on
Amazon you can get it at their website
and learn more about the coaching that
they're doing as well and how you can
connect to them with all of their
process to help you reset the narrative
and uh we'll get that success that you
are due full Focus dot Co is again the
website talk about one of the uh
examples of somebody you've done this
with when you're coaching something that
pops into head because I know there's
lots of success stories well one of the
success stories is mine actually I had a
debilitating fear of public speaking and
this is like number one fear that
everybody has that's like all of America
all of America but in my situation I'm a
CEO at the time I was a CEO of our
company and I had kept this hidden for
many many years and it had kind of
developed in high school never examined
it and my team came to me one day and
said hey we want to do a big live event
have you keynote in front of 800 people
and I did kind of like that nervous
laugh like okay yeah you know I'll say
yes inside I'm thinking this is my worst
nightmare yeah and I just die now and
get it over right I thought that if I
got on stage I would be publicly
humiliated I would lose control of my
body I mean you know just talk about
catastrophizing to the Max and so I
hired a speech coach I hired an anxiety
coach I like got all the help that I
could possibly get and for six weeks I
went through the process of rewriting
that story and fast forward I was able
to step on stage in front of 800 people
for the first time and it was amazing it
played out exactly like the story that I
had written and I'm not talking about
affirmations like you know that's
scoring a touchdown the Super Bowl spike
it do the dance all right you know what
I mean ding ding it was amazing and it
was this exact process it's part of the
reason we wrote this book very cool hey
you guys we appreciate your friendship
all these years we appreciate what you
do for people and if you guys have not
plugged in for some reason to Michael
Hyatt over these years he's been doing
this a long time helping people Megan is
uh obviously The Heir Apparent running
the show today and uh allowing Michael
to work on books and these things mind
your mindset the science that shows
success starts with your thinking go get
don't stop get it right now Amazon click
it right now shut up do it this is what
you're doing this is a Ramsay
recommendation I don't tell you to read
junk I'll tell you what to do that's
going to help you this is going to help
you and it's right along the lines of
the other stuff we're talking about on
the show every day mind your mindset get
it right now thanks for coming guys
thanks Dave thanks for having us
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author we appreciate you folks being
with us hey we kicked off our Building
Wealth live tour here in Nashville a few
weeks ago on February 16th just a couple
of weeks we're going to be in
Indianapolis with Rachel Cruz George
Campbell and Jade warshaw Austin Texas
February 23rd with Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney and Jade warshaw I'll be in all
of these uh April 24th we're heading to
Salt Lake City with the Retro Cruise
George Campbell and Christine L is
sitting to my right then Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney and Christina Ellis will be
with me in Anaheim for May the 2nd the
final
Building Wealth live event of the season
of this spring season if you want to
come with us that's May 2nd we'd love to
have you tickets for only 49 you can get
a four pack starting as low as 175.
seats are selling fast get your seats
before they're gone 175 you pay four
times that to go see a music concert
and when you're done you have a t-shirt
and have had some fun and that's a good
thing you should do that I went to an
Eagles concert a while back it's fun
it's a lot of fun
and uh I mean Finn skill is an eagle
that's pretty cool you know so we go and
it's pretty pretty fun and they did a
great job and uh I spent more than 175
to go to that concert and um each and
with my bride so it was like more and so
yeah and I I enjoyed it and I'm not mad
at music concerts but don't be broke and
go into a music concert instead of doing
this and bring three of your friends
right so ramseysolutions.com events 175
for four people
49 ahead
ramsaysolutions.com events come out we'd
love to have you it's a big pep rally
for those of you that are on the plan uh
you get to be around a whole bunch of
people doing what you're doing Dixie's
with us in Allentown Pennsylvania hi
Dixie welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi it's an honor to be talking to you
today you too what's up in your world
well I am wondering what you would
as I'm a teacher this is my 25th year of
teaching but I do have a unique living
situation and I am considering finding a
new career but I'm wondering if I should
take an early retirement which would
involve a penalty in my pension
and what I would have coverage with my
medical insurance in so MediCare at this
age or should I freeze my pension
and
um have a you know take a career with a
lesser income kind of starting over and
no insurance guarantee
what kind of career are you thinking
um corporate training since I'm a
teacher I have a degree as an
instructional designer as well
you know what would you make as a
corporate trainer
uh maybe sixty thousand
what are you making right now as a
teacher
92. okay you're gonna be an independent
contractor corporate trainer or working
for a certain company
probably working for a certain company
well they would have insurance
wouldn't they
company big enough to have corporate
trainers is big enough to have an
insurance policy
okay right I think so too yes I'm just
I'm just worried that maybe it won't be
out there I don't think I would make
this decision based on the insurance
I would go buy insurance before I would
take it on the channel my pension now
the other the the other side of the coin
for different reasons I might take the
pension now the reason you take less now
how old are you
48 when's it kick in 65 or 59
um I think
full insurance no full full pension not
counting Insurance we're not doing this
on insurance we're doing the pension I
believe I can I think it can take early
retirement at 55. and start getting a
full pension then
uh 57. okay I'll have I'll have enough
time okay so nine years
if you wait nine years you can if you
freeze it you can get full right
yes if you take it early you get less
than full so the question then is a
financial calculation question that you
would sit with a smart investor Pro so
even if you don't need the money and you
don't need the money because you're
gonna go be a corporate trainer and you
don't need the insurance because you're
going to go get insurance even if you
don't need the money you may want to
take it early because of the What's
called the present value of money
a thousand dollars today invested
in 10 years
would be three thousand dollars
okay okay and then okay and so that are
that lesser pension invested for nine
years might offset for the rest of your
life the Lesser pension
and the money's in your hands because if
you die you know what happens that
pension bye bye
it goes away yes and so if the money's
in your hands it doesn't go bye-bye
right so I'm going to try to take it
early and not use it and invest it
wisely in good mutual funds if the math
says to do that if they're discounting
it too heavily you wait and take the
chance anyway but if they're not
discounting it that much because
probably what they're using is a present
value calculation based on about a seven
percent red return which tells me that
if you were to invest it at 12 that you
will come out ahead taking it early
yes okay that's probably what you're
going to find but they can they you
could be all over the map as to what
they use to run these calculations and
pensions they're they're not
there there's not a regulation that
makes them do it a certain way so you
have to get with somebody help you do
the math so click smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com and the only reason
you take it early is to reinvest it and
end up with more money because you did
that
you don't take it early because of the
insurance and stay on the line we're
going to get you a copy from paycheck to
purpose by Ken Coleman just as you
navigate this transition because I can
hear a little bit of fear in your voice
and some of that hesitancy in this
transition and I think that could really
help you just kind of walk through it
that's a that's a big career leap yeah
you're pretty much done in the classroom
we can all hear that too Matson Sioux
City Iowa hi Matt welcome to Ramsey Show
hey Matt uh hey Dave this is Matt how
are you guys doing better than we
deserve how can we help yeah hey uh just
uh I've been designed for a while about
a year and a half and now I'm at baby
step four through six and I'm just
curious where I should be allocating my
money it's pretty easy with baby step
four 15 I have one kid uh so I'm just
wondering she's about a year and a half
how much should I put into my 529 I'm
looking at term life insurance I've got
a mortgage of 135 000
um and then you know I'm interested in S
P 500 so just curious if you're in my
shoes where would you allocate your
money well congratulations that's great
baby steps four through six woohoo
I love it yeah it's been really exciting
and you know being it's all intense
listening to you guys definitely helped
me so I appreciate you guys as uh wisdom
that you've given me throughout that
time well we're excited for you and I
love that you've broken down the numbers
so you have a pretty good handle on it
and I know with baby step five the
college portion it can be a little bit
confusing because you're not really sure
you know what that future looks like but
we have a really good calculator on our
website at ramseysolutions.com you can
look at the college cost calculator and
with that you can you know type in how
many years you have left to save where
you anticipate she might go to school
and it'll break down about how much you
should be saving a month in order to hit
that tuition goal so I would go ahead
and do that so you can kind of have an
idea of how much you need to be putting
aside in the 529. and then you know once
you've done your 15 towards retirement
you've got your 529 then it's just time
to go crazy on the house do what you can
to pay that off yeah SMP 500 is a baby
step 7 thing you don't need to do any of
that until you get there but everything
else you mentioned it's just a matter of
how much and sometimes people say I'm
going to put a hundred dollars a month
towards college and then I'm going to
pour all of it on the house get the
house done and then I'll cash flow
college sometimes people say I'm going
to do college the proper amount with the
calculator the way Christina said and
that's going to reduce how much I put on
the house so I'm gonna have the house
dead a little bit longer either one of
those are great answers stupid is not in
either one of those columns you are
right on track and you're heading the
right way you're doing the right kinds
of things and so the trick is for again
just for to make you stay on track with
four five and six if it doesn't fall in
four or five or six right now you're
you're not doing it unless you're
intentionally saying I'm going to punish
five or six so I can buy a car I'm going
to punish 5 five or six so we can go on
this vacation I'm going to punish five
or six so we can dot dot dot and if you
punish them completely there'll be
nothing there so you know you can't do
that but it's okay to say hey time to
get a couch uh the heat and air is out
we're gonna pay cash for it and that's
going to mean we put a little less on
the house this month or next month this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day Matthew 11 27
and 28 come to me all you who are weary
and burdened and I will give you rest
take my yoke upon you
and learn from me for I am gentle and
humble in heart and you will find rest
for your souls the words of Jesus
Corey ten Boone said now I know in my
experience that Jesus's light is
stronger than the biggest Darkness well
amen and amen and amen it's beautiful
Christine Alice Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Patrick is with us in
Tucson Arizona hi Patrick how are you
I'm great how are you today better than
I deserve what's up
hey so I just had a quick question here
I was going through some of your older
Dave rants on uh on YouTube and heard
one about gold and I agree with you that
mutual funds are definitely a better
investment in the long term than gold I
also agree that people would not be
trading gold bars for blue jeans or
whatever in the event of a major
economic collapse but
um where I would uh kind of challenge a
bit is as far as gold goes I would look
at it more as like an insurance policy
to kind of preserve the wealth in the
event of some sort of major economic
situation if you have some of your
wealth in Gold then presumably if there
was some sort of collapse of a currency
and a new currency were to come up that
wealth would maintain its value at least
somewhat through the transition and uh
and then when he's out at the other side
you still have you know you wouldn't
have lost everything right
the problem is that since the Roman
Empire you can't find an example of that
happening
of of people using gold to pursue to
survive an economic collapse and it
holds its value and they come back and
turn a corner on a currency it never has
happened
well I mean if we look at um I know in
in your previous uh you know rant on on
gold you had mentioned the uh um the the
Confederacy right and if you know
um at that time people did use gold as
currency and anybody who had gold as
currency
um and if they kept that instead of
transitioning to the Confederate money
um then once that Confederate dollars
collapsed they'd still have that value
in the gold same thing with you know the
economic collapse in um uh in Germany in
the 1920s and and you know and so on
well I mean you can convert to assets of
all kinds of things in the event of an
economic collapse uh that will write it
out uh
you know
that I I think the thing you've got to
think about here is
where can you find what you're talking
about actually being used
by wealthy people people that have built
wealth
to cause them to hold on to wealth and
to grow wealth you just can't find it
Patrick
um and you're spending too much time on
the internet
um yeah Patrick what are your worries
gonna happen
I mean I I'm I'm somewhat of a prepper
myself so I'm not worried so to speak
that everything is going to collapse
tomorrow but I think when you look at a
long enough time frame or for your
theory to work in your lifetime the U.S
dollar would have to completely have had
no value like Confederate money did
or like Iranian money did under Saddam
Hussein
you would have to have the US dollar the
largest economy in the history of the
world become worth nothing for your
theory to work
and I'm sorry I'm not buying it
so would there be something else that
you would say is a is a better thing to
um to look at to protect yourself from a
um from a financial I'm not planning for
the Apocalypse
I don't do financial planning for the
apocalypse I don't have anything for the
apocalypse the best thing I've got for
Apocalypse is several thousand rounds
but um uh so I'll be eating but other
than that I'm not you know I'm not
planning for the apocalypse I'm not
doing financial planning for the
apocalypse I'm not predicting the end of
time and I'm not going to predict my my
life as if everything as We Know It in
America today becomes valueless
I'm not going to set my mind on that
track I'm not going to set my friends on
that track and I'm not going to set you
on that track if you want to get on that
track Patrick you can find a way to
rationalize all that negativity if you
want but I'm I just don't believe it
and and I and I think it leads you to
ridiculous places to put money
uh and so I buy real estate and I buy
mutual funds so you know you don't have
to agree with me uh you get you a show
and you talk about gold that'll be great
but I'm not doing it I'm not going to
suggest you do it right well and one of
the best ways to prepare for financial
collabs if you're thinking that might be
a thing is to walk through the baby
steps and actually become wealthy I've
talked to different point is all that
wealth would disappear right but here's
the thing I have talked to Preppers
before who are still in debt
that's a problem like that is actually
well that's believing more in the
collapse than it is in the non-collapse
right because in the non-collapse you
would want to get rid of the debt but in
a collapse so that would be a great
thing because you got you never paid it
back
and you're counting on the end of time I
mean this is like
um you know it's a it's a theological
doctrinal problem as well as a uh just a
philosophy of life and so you know I I'm
not a prepper not mad at you if you're a
prepper uh but I'm not a prepper I'm not
predicting the end of Life as We Know It
While I'm Alive
um and so I'm not going to say that the
US dollar is going to become worth
absolutely the same thing as the Iranian
dollar with Saddam Hussein's face on it
which is absolutely paper money or
Monopoly money or Confederate money or
any other collapsed economy in former
currencies you would have for this idea
to work that you would have to assume
the US dollar is going to do that and I
just think that that's an asinine set of
assumptions
I mean it's just there's nothing that
indicates that but even if you are a
prepper get out of debt start there like
if you're really trying to be prepared
for some Financial collapse like
Financial collapse probably wouldn't
happen overnight anyways it could drag
out for 10 or 20 years so it's like even
if you think that's gonna happen get out
of debt pay off your house build wealth
that'll help you be prepared for
anything I own real estate a lot of it
and so uh but guess what in a financial
collapse a Communist Regime comes in
takes over all private property
potentially
um so that can be taken away oh by the
way they could come take your gold bars
too
because they just decided to they come
take your farm
they shoot people
and take their stuff
this is how Russia was formed hello I
mean the Bolsheviks the the gulags I
mean that they went and killed the
farmers and took their Farms
that's what communism does so if you how
do you protect gold bars aren't gonna
protect you from that you know and
neither is debt free and nothing you
know so I'm just not going to financial
plan for the apocalypse I'm not going to
do it uh if you want to you can
but you're you know
that shirt you can do a lot of stupid
stuff if you want to but it's loud out
there but it's not what we're going to
teach you to do well and it's living in
that world of fear like it's living in
that space of everything is bad the
world is going bad and it's like when
you're in that space of no I will tell
you one thing he did get me on one thing
that he's exactly right on that if you
took your Confederate money and you
converted it to Gold Bars before the
Confederacy collapsed
the gold was worth something after that
and the Confederate money wasn't
and he's right I did I I was wrong about
that
so it did it did cause you to survive
the collapsed economy because you could
have took the gold and sold it for
Northern dollars right called US Dollars
now and you know you would have
converted your wealth and not lost your
wealth so he is actually right about
that but you for for him to be right
though to do this you would have to
assume the collapse of the dollar like
the Confederate dollar become worth
nothing and I'm just I'm just not gonna
set my life up on that hinge if you want
to it's okay I'm not really not mad at
you
um I just think you're wrong and you
think I'm wrong so there you go so go do
what you want to do that's how it works
that's okay it's okay it's fine it's
fine I you know uh if the US dollar
collapses I'm wrong
well I just say let's not live our lives
in fear yeah
let's build wealth and choose Joy he is
not a plan that puts us out of the Rams
are showing the books we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started